what's going on Rejects is Grego buddy
and it's Joan Humphrey are are we're
going to continue our retro movie review
series of the Pirates of the Caribbean
pirates in the Caribbean heck yeah
pirates part 3 at worlds and worlds a
directed by Edgar Wright starring Simon
Pegg hey I would buy that anyway yeah so
this one is our the toss-up between the
worst ones the franchise thus far if you
have any men tell no tales is part three
and part 4 okay so this one I know our
retro review sir has been a little
longer it do our best keep this one
shorter today
Bret again this one ah oh boy I am man I
just don't like this movie I got it I
gotta be honest with you man there are
things ended i taste thing from
beginning to end the tone of this movie
is terrible it's so dour so gloomy from
start to finish it's just the exact
opposite of fun why would you want to
sit through three hours of no fun the
entire time yeah or or without enough
fun like put in to keep us interesting
cuz the second movies like darker but
but yeah there's no life enough movie I
feel like they brought the same amount
of humor to the third movie as they did
the second movie but the second the
third movies like so much sicker that's
like those jokes pop up like once every
half hour
yeah like I I get what you're saying I
honestly like it's been a couple days I
I don't hate pirates 3 but I acknowledge
all the problems with it and I'm not
sure I would ever want to sit down and
watch it again but I do think I don't
know like everybody prepared me for this
terrible movie and so I don't like
elements that I like about it and what's
so upsetting to me what disappointed me
is like they don't come together to form
a cohesive whole no and that's a bummer
well I think this movies and just so
over it just over convoluted it's got so
many elements that
I don't know I don't like a lot of the
elements I'm not a fan of what they do
with Keira Knightley becoming the you
know the Sigma for Pirate King or
whatever the hell her and her title is
specifically in that yeah I find it
rather I don't know it felt it felt more
like we got to make her a pirate -
should we do that yeah let's do that
you're a pirate as well I guess like
just to sum it all into something
there's no other way for me to put it
other than the film is just dull to me
it's a really dull movie and the action
sequences are not that interesting to me
either it's like very sporadic for what
I find interesting is like oh here's a
cool shot every once in a while and
there are elements that I keep thinking
I'll find cool or latch on to like I
kind of like Johnny Depp having you know
the going a little crazy and seeing like
more Jack Sparrow's everywhere he goes
he's kind of had a split personality
thing going on and there are elements of
that that I kind of like yeah at the
same time though I just there's nothing
here that I walk away from going I
really like that film
I really like this aspect of that movie
because even the finales is so so uh
it's so over packing they got the
build-up to a Calypso the entire time
and she does jack [ __ ] yeah great to
watch like it's kind of cool when she
becomes a giant yeah like oh [ __ ] maybe
all this dark depressing crap is gonna
pay off to something yeah and she does
nothing she creates a whirlpool for them
to fight in and that's all she does she
creates a whirlpool yes the bummer cause
she became like I forgot how much I
loved watching her do her thing well
Naomi Harris playing Tia dama in the the
second movie and then the third movie
and I was like oh cool they made our old
bigger this is great I love watching you
and then yeah just sort of Peters out
and a lot of things do in Pirates three
because it's so thick and it's so long
it and no none of the characters at all
not that they're supposed to be having a
good time but like everyone is
having a shitty time last movie and it's
hard to kind of get through after a
while because everyone is AC like
everything about pirate 3 to me feels
like angst right now to the construction
of it movie it's a lumpy movie and
that's the front like that's what's
upsetting me like I said I think the
production values are still great I
think the way it's not order feels great
I think a lot of the cast is still great
well that's why I always bring back the
problem to being the tone of the film
yeah and I think their ideas are good
but yeah it's just the execution like
the tone and the proportions of like how
the plot is yeah sure like that and
their Islamic lurches man or something
dragged on to three hours like it's like
10 minutes shy of three hours for a film
that dragged on for that long and still
feel like how did you not flush this out
better couch it and some parts are just
kind of confusing we have to pause the
movie at a couple points to go wait a
minute wait a minute I think it gets
confusing because the phone's hard to
keep your attention span completely
engaged throughout yeah because because
it lacks slightly as I was watching it I
remember I won't fight I did make a
comment going Johnny that's the best
part of this he still is the bad part is
the mugging liveleak thing in them yeah
cuz the only times a genuine laugh
occurs is from Johnny Depp doing
something that's kind of funny like the
only moments I could think of that I
enjoy our a couple of Johnny Depp jokes
like I love the bit with Barbosa
who could with the telescope I mean yeah
listen what I called yeah like a fella
joinable veteran issue it is obvious
guilt it to overpower him yeah and the
film goes into shoes like you know like
when I when I looked at this film in
retrospect of how the first one starts
off in reasonably grounded pirate world
with some mystical elements and then the
second one keeps humor in the first half
of it and gets a lot darker in the
second half and then has more even more
mystical elements here this one just
flows which is pure darkness has so much
mysticism and I don't mind the mysticism
but I do mind when they start to ignore
the rules of their universe and the laws
of physics and they just stop caring
about how things work and I'm even
bigger problem in the fourth movie but
yeah it's like they're fighting in that
whirlpool forever and I'm like yeah
cliff so doesn't seem like she wants to
just give you a stage - yeah yeah I'm
like what what's happening here or why
aren't you just falling into the a bit
like there's a lot of there's a lot of
weird so I feel like this movie could
have greatly benefited from two or three
more drafts because I think all the
ideas are there I don't hate any of
their ideas I like the whole like pirate
council thing like I get the three line
they're going for and I do kind of
respect the three of these movies having
seen them all now I'd like one long
piece but each one gets a little more
meandering and a little less discipline
each time we aired one if the service is
the the problem with the Thoreau incus
like we said like it could does complete
the story it completes the trilogy of
Pirates of the Caribbean because if I
watched 1 and 2 I have to watch part 3
even if I don't want even though I
thought I liked the film it's read to me
it's just add ready film and I dread
watching much as well it's is so far
from the enjoyable to me and but you
know at the end of the day it does wrap
up the story like you feel like you
watch the complete story and I can see
it like the comparisons like when you
watch The Matrix Revolutions you know
like you can't see like it's not exactly
a fun movie revolutions and it's
definitely the weakest of the three but
you kinda just got to watch it to
complete the story well and I think a
lot I think that's moving made up a lot
of ground for me partly because of you
know the hype around it was just like
you're gonna hate this
and I don't but you know I I feel like
the hype watch of the second time yeah
second seconds the first time I was like
there are a lot of it's like spider-man
3 to me I'm like oh this is a bummer
because there are a lot of redeeming
factors and I don't think that looks
like this part 3 still feels like they
were really trying like everyone showed
on that movie so as dour as it is as
thick as it is it seems like they really
went the mile to put it all on screen
and I do
did get swept into it a time or two
because of that is yeah a couple that I
couldn't recall it I can only think of
like tidbit moments that I like I can't
think of a sequence that I really even
even giant whirlpool finale I couldn't I
couldn't just fully get hooked into that
I
okay I'm like this is dragging on and
there's I mean it's moments that's at
work but there's never a full sequence
or seem that I'm like that was good that
was great I can't think of one full
thing yeah that's totally variances no I
don't disagree with you on but I do I in
a weird way even though I don't think
it's this is really the right way to go
for these pirates movies just given what
they are and where they came from part
way through in an odd way I sort of
started to respect like wow you it seems
like they took the time to throw down on
making an epic like not just a
blockbuster but they threw down on
making it epic with ships and splintered
wood and even though the third one has
more CG I do appreciate the Lord of the
Rings approach words like we're going to
try and do a lot of makeup and we're
going to try and go to a lot of places
and sets and make this feel
world-spanning because even it's worse
the scope still feels massive oh it does
yeah yeah oh yeah I'll give I'll give it
that I don't think by any means it's a
lazy film I would never say that about
at world and I just think it's execution
it is just how leaves a sour taste in my
mouth yes because you cuz you know like
they have all this bit I feel like this
could have been simplified you know like
if you if you break down the basic plot
of at World's End it goes we got a
rescue jackets barrow so we can take
down Beckett in the East India Trading
Company who is now ruling the seas when
you're watching the film you're kind of
forgetting about all that because
there's so much other crap going on left
and right here and nightly weather a
thing Orlando Bloom with his dad or
whatever the hell Jack the motivation is
and all this yeah or boasted and the
Pirates and and it doesn't ever feel
cohesively put together to the point
where I'm on board for the plot on
what's going on so by the time they take
down Beckett and granted I like the race
I like the moment when Beckett's taken
down
I love I do love the part of how Jack
Sparrow decides to let Orlando Bloom
become Davy Jones I like that they have
that touch in there I even like the
moment when the flying dutchman comes up
Orlando Bloom has a whole new change of
clothes
yeah a new guy even but I like that and
when they worked when they work together
and they throw Beckett off like the how
the plan comes into full fruition where
they take down Beckett ship with my
using the Black Pearl and the Dutchman
and that whole slow-motion sequence of
Beckett facing his death what I thought
was really well done even though that's
still being said I didn't feel like a
victory I didn't feel in my heart yeah
victory after all of that you just kind
of feel like falling over oh no long a
spinelli a super long ass finale like
watching that movie is kind of like
being there because once it's all done
you're just like uh yeah I just want to
go to bed yeah I don't even feel like
celebrating but you know I don't know I
yeah I get all the complaints about this
movie but I do think especially watching
it back to back of parkour I think there
are a lot of redeeming factors because
part four is what I thought I was going
to get out of part three is what
everybody prepared me for was this
different thing so I don't know is going
in and I was watching more reviews this
morning it seems like everybody kind of
hates just anything past the first one
like even the second one a lot of people
don't like that movie and I don't high
versus anyone I love it yeah I really I
love I would say I love the second one
but but it's been sticking up for Matt
this film right here and a couple of
other because I feel like it's easy to
complain about this film and I want to
try to take some time for moments I
liked it you know I actually really like
that super cheesy moment when wilt oh
yeah there's that other plot line raah
Oh will it Elizabeth or together
oh yeah I get why are you doing this
thing where we know they're going to get
back together in some way just let them
just go there we don't even have to be a
part don't do it yeah but but I even
when I do I ever some reason I do like
that cheesy ass moment when they're like
married meat you know and then barbosa's
marrying them in the middle of this
crazy bad a little bit
well because finally you got back that
weird back and forth between like the
fun kind of out of place yeah and the
swashbuckling adventure like that's a
scene that kind of demonstrates what I
do people love about the series that the
first one happened so well I feel like
everyone loses the reins on the balance
you know each time the second one a
little bit in the third one a lot but
yeah I thought that seeing that I
thought it would be annoyed by that
scene from the trailer and I actually
really liked it and I and I could
nitpick so much but any time we saw a
problem that we just pointed out when we
were watching like little MIT take stuff
like when they're in the whirlpool and
Davy Jones and Jack are fighting on top
of that like cattle and I'm thinking how
the hell is Jack balancing himself I'm
also thinking Davey Jones could appear
anywhere how can we have me kill Jack
like walk through yeah like what the
heck does this whole fight that they're
having and then at one point he just
takes his big you know kradic law yeah
and then slap slap this arm like this
whole fight he could easily kill Jack
this entire fight me would have been
simple a walk in the park for him yeah
that he doesn't even have a heart for
Jack to penetrate he could just go up to
Jack let him stab him in the kill little
bit like there's a billion different
ways David Jones gonna kill him yeah I'm
like David Jones just I don't know why
he didn't make that choice to do it I
don't quite get like here and Knightley
it's so good at sword fighting all the
sudden when she have nowhere near the
amount of experience with fighting
people as any of the countless people
she's fighting he'll drain abyss for how
long is it between those two movies and
even it in my edit so I could get hung
up on that or even the whole I mean even
when you see all the Pirates come
together where they're giving their
items and you know giving their ideas of
eight the pieces of the nine pieces of
eight even that seemed kind of annoying
but I feel like the nitpicks every time
I we had a nificant like this one has
much bigger problems than any of these
[ __ ] just without I kept feeling like
because there is much bigger problem
than any of these things I feel like
part of what's proven to be a gift in
the curse at least of the first three
the Gore Verbinski pirates movies that
they take their time and in the first
one like that was part of what made it
so charming is it's a real movie it's
not just you know a big extravaganza and
two and three take their time but that
doesn't always work in your favor
especially with the plot is getting so
convoluted and it's like yeah you can
nitpick you know a lot of little things
but it doesn't ultimately that was all
pale in comparison to what they did with
the structure and tone because the thing
is a lot of those nitpicks could have
worked perhaps in a lighter movie like
pirates or that before but you could
forgive a lot of these like because
cartoony moments don't work in a film
that takes himself so darting serious Oh
Ward it really does the third one
especially feels like a war movie at sea
you know like it's sea life and
cannonballs and and you know we're
heading to our death at any time boys so
yeah we can't you can't just get wacky
while you're doing that head and I guess
and to wrap this up I mean a couple
things I do I do like the ending with
Jack how he loses the Pearl again
yeah there's no like it's a funny moment
it blows off those two women and his
relationship with gives is so funny and
I even like to seeing with orlando bloom
and keira knightley having to say
goodbye to each other I do and I
appreciated the post-credits scene
because it adds to the plot because and
I didn't really notice that until this
time around because Davey Jones and
Calypso have a scene where he's talking
about I came back to the island you
weren't there
my dad they a story was good yeah and
then they have a post-credits scene
where you see Will Turner return so like
oh he's not he's not the Davy Jones that
he's got the cave of a captain of the
Flying Dutchman that Davy Jones turned
out to be well interns for Elizabeth
Swann to see his child with all that
what she returns for him yeah she was
rebel digging right right up so to come
back
right it's in nature that's evil man she
got a flow I don't know that I would
give this film like a negative a hundred
directors I don't like it let's don't
just let you guys not gonna like it
I'll give it a half a John alright I'll
give it points for trying all you know
what to call me crazy but honestly Keira
Knightley on Orlando Bloom left a bigger
impression on me in this movie in part
two I'll give that to her honestly their
performances I thought we were at least
even though again angst I was like well
at least you're leaving you're standing
out of this movie again yeah save the
movie alright subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification Bell
check out our exclusive perks on patreon
my friends John that John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager of Blum house calm we're on our
way to review the next Pirates on
Stranger Tides
today we're going to watch dead men tell
no tales tonight hell yes you guys soon